à
mais la meinau et messieurs bonjour et
bien l'actualité de ce jeudi 26 février
et marquée par la fin du séjour officiel
du président georges pompidou à
washington par la situation toujours un
cri inquiétante dans les alpes où
persiste la menace d'avalanche et enfin
par une situation également grave
sur le front des inondations nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure mais d'abord
il faut parler du séjour du président et
de madame pompidou à washington et bien
c'est séjour s'achève donc aujourd'hui
avec un ultime entretien que le chef de
l'état français va avoir ce matin même
avec le président nixon le président
doit ensuite se rendre à cap kennedy où
il visitera les installations de la nasa
et puis il prendra ensuite l'avion à
destination de san francisco jaras bac
nous allons revenir sur la journée
d'hier qui a été particulièrement
important lui aurait fait la journée
d'hier du président pompidou a été
particulièrement chargée le programme ne
prévoyait pratiquement aucune pause une
allocution devant le congrès a déjeuné
chez monsieur william rogers
le secrétaire d'état américain des
entretiens à politique au département
d'état un discours devant le congrès
américain
une réception avec une trentaine de
sénateurs et à la fin de ce marathon un
dîner à ambassade de france
c'est la première fois que le président
nixon accepte de dîner dans une
ambassade étrangère depuis le début de
son mandat présidentiel a dîné très
élégant ou 60 couverts étaient servis
vous voyez ici monsieur pompidou
accueillant le président nixon
madame pompidou qui depuis le début ce
voyage s'est fait remarquer par toutes
les élégantes américaine portait une
robe longue violette en mousseline à
manches longues
madame nixon quant à elle portait une
robe rose saumon relever d'un collier de
diamants
monsieur pompidou a prononcé comme il se
doit une petite allocution il a affirmé
les liens d'amitié qui existent entre la
france et les états unis
il a ajouté cette amitié et une
importance plus grande encore sur le
plan moral et sentimental que dans les
domaines parfois aride de la politique
et de la coopération technique
quant à monsieur nixon dans sa réponse
il a affirmé que tout américain avait
deux patries la sienne et la france
parlant des entretiens qu'il avait eus
avec monsieur pompidou il a souligné que
la france et les etats unis sont en
général d'accord sur les problèmes
essentiels dans l'après midi donc
monsieur pompidou s'était rendu
congré ou devant les sénateurs il avait
parlé des grands problèmes
internationaux donc le proche orient
voici d'ailleurs ce qu'il a dit à ce
sujet
comme on évoquerait ge pas également le
conflit du moyen orient se jugeant
menacé dans son existence
l'état d'israël a déclenché une action
préventive qui lui a valu sur le terrain
d'indéniables succès
la france a marqué sa position dans des
conditions qui ont été souvent critiquée
ou mal comprises fidèle à la résolution
des nations unies que nos deux pays ont
voté
je réaffirme ici le droit de l'état
d'israël
non seulement à l'existence mais aussi à
la sécurité et au libre exercice de tous
les droits
un état indépendant et souverain
mais y devenir le caractère précaire et
finalement stérile des succès militaires
qui le comprend qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir
assuré pour israël
en dehors d'une entente durable avec le
monde qui l'entourent entente qui
implique le renoncement à la conquête
par les armes et la solution et problème
palestinien
un tel résultat dans un milieu monde
chaque jour les passions et les
fanatismes devrait pour être atteint
rapidement procédé de l'action des
nations unies et en particulier de
l'accord des quatre membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité pour définir
et proposer des conditions générales
d'un règlement et en mettre au point et
garante
peu après le président pompidou quitter
le congrès une foule nombreuse se
pressait de part et d'autre de la large
avenue qui devaient emprunter
passons au milieu de la garde d'honneur
l'ensemble des journalistes américains
sont d'accord pour affirmer que le
président pompidou a réussi son examen
de passage devant les sénateurs il a été
applaudi à huit reprises en plus du
proche orient
il a évoqué la guerre du vietnam à ce
propos il a déclaré la fin de la guerre
du vietnam sera pour les états unis la
plus précieuse et victoire celle que
l'on remporte sur soi-même également une
ovation de plus de deux minutes de toute
l'assistance lorsque évoquant par les
astronautes américains
la conquête de la lune monsieur pompidou
déclara c'est une victoire de l'humanité
tout entière
un mot sur le programme de la journée de
monsieur pompidou sa dernière journée à
washington une visite officielle au
cimetière militaire d'arlington
un dernier entretien politique avec
monsieur nixon puis en fin d'après midi
le président de la république et sa
suite quitteront washington pour se
rendre à cap kennedy
c'est en marge de la session ce bac en
marge de cette visite dans les milieux
diplomatiques américains il y a ce matin
une rumeur de démission celle de
monsieur sargent shriver qui est
actuellement l'ambassadeur des
etats-unis à paris
il semble que monsieur serge leiber
veille disons un peu se reconvertir
quitté un peu la vie diplomatique pour
se consacrer à la vie politique je crois
qu'il faudrait se présenter aux
élections
absolument ou bien je voudrais avoir une
petite parenthèse pour vous dire que le
le député sud vietnamien qui depuis
lundi rester enfermé à l'assemblée
nationale de saigon car il est accusé de
contacts d'espionnage avec les
communistes pour la bonne raison que son
frère lui même et communistes et bien ce
député qui s'était réfugié alors à
l'assemblée nationale depuis lundi et
qu'il n'avait pas quitté qui recevaient
dès vivres et de la part des bonzes et
bien ce député a été arrêté ce matin à
l'instant je reviens au séjour à
washington du président pompidou pour
dire que depuis washington le président
pompidou a exprimé son émotion de voir
la catastrophe de lanslevillard et cela
nous amène évidemment à parler de ces
avalanches la menace subsiste du fait du
radoucissement de la température la
montagne a déjà fait en huit jours
quarante morts à val d'isère 8 allanche
le villars et à reckingen on en est
actuellement à 16 morts il ne se passe
pas d'heure sans que l'on découvre un
nouveau cadavre car il ya une quinzaine
de disparus bien entendu il n'y a
pratiquement plus aucune chance de
retrouver vivants ces disparus il y à 50
heures que cette catastrophe de
reckingen s'est produite et l'on n'ose
pas croire que le miracle c'est un peu
le mot que l'on peut employer qui s'est
produit à lanslevillard pourrait se
reproduire vous savez qu'on a retrouvés
sains et saufs après 21h passer sous la
neige
un couple de parisiens chirurgien et sa
jeune femme
ce couple de parisiens avaient été
proches protéger de la pression de la
neige par un lien en bronze qui s'était
retourné qui les avait abrité et qui
avait permis que se crée une poche d'air
qui leur a évité de s'asphyxier
les sauveteurs ont été guidés
vers ce couple de parisiens par leurs
appels et dans la recherche des
personnes ensevelies par les avalanches
les chiens sont très souvent de précieux
auxiliaires de l'homme et l'on ne compte
plus les personnes repérées par le flair
des chiens d'avalanche quelques-uns de
ces chiens ont été présentés ce matin à
paris et monsieur clément qui est le
directeur de l'école française de chiens
d'avalanche a déploré quelques les
municipalités ne fasse pratiquement
jamais appel à ces chiens voici ce qu'il
a déclaré à andré forestier avoir un
chien
les fans sont pas considérables non mais
vous savez toujours pareil prendre de
l'argent c'est facile et un chien un
chien à nourrir c'est ce pour une
station c'est véritablement ce n'est pas
un heureux parce que c'est dur a dressé
un chaînon un chien à l'école de chiens
d'avalanche ont fait en moyenne trois
ans de stage de dix jours pour avoir un
bon chien l'avalanche c'est à dire qu'on
voulait un mois un chien est dressé oui
on vous dans un mois on peut s'en servir
il faut déjà détecté naturellement plus
travail plus vu le chien prend
conscience de son métier et le chien de
loin le plus efficace dans ces cas là
naturellement puisqu'ils ont regardé
quand vous avez par exemple à la pyrrhus
qui est moi qui ai passé la déneigeuse
et 24 assure encore comment voulez vous
même des hélicoptères qui passe au
dessus comment voulez vous savoir s'il
ya quelqu'un au dessus et son décès très
bien sont des mais le général mangou
mais les chiens en premier s'il n'y a
pas de s'il n'y a pas moyen d'avoir de
résultats avec les chiens chose qui est
très rare à ce moment là nous pouvons
mettre les sondeurs tissu derrière le
chien mais laisser la chance aux chiens
mais c'est ça a été prouvé en suisse à
l'école de la bosse comme un chien en
moyenne ils ont essayé avec des
appareils le chien il y avait trois
personnes d'enterrer le en rang minutes
les trois personnes ont été retrouvées
et au bout de 28 minutes ils ont réussi
avec leurs appareils américains lors
appelé hier à dix a déterré la première
personne gratuit minutes l'inondation
est bien la situation ne s'améliore pas
loin de là à paris la seine a encore
monté de 20 cm cette nuit à latin ce
matin cinq mètres 22 au pont
d'austerlitz à villeneuve saint georges
elle a envahi plusieurs pavillons et
nous allons voir une photo de cette
petite fille qui est lui
des élèves de l'école de villeneuve
saint georges qui en est réduite à se
déplacer sur le dos d'un pompier comme
il n'y a pas un pompier pas relève bien
enfin appellent également à des barques
depuis quelques jours vous savez que
nous faisons le tour de france des
inondations car rares sont les cours
d'eau qui ne sont pas sortis de leur lit
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est sur les bords
de la marne que nous allons nous rentrer
après avoir marqué un léger recul en
début de semaine la crue de la marne a
pris des proportions inquiétantes
à la suite des pluies de ces dernières
48 heures à saint dizier lejard
disparaît sous les eaux ce qui fait la
joie des enfants amateurs de navigation
miniature les sapeurs pompiers sont en
état d' alerte et assure avec leurs
barbes la desserte des quartiers in
oblique en haute-marne l'on ne compte
plus les routes submergées la
circulation est de ce fait difficile
voire même impossible
le village de ses lisières qui se trouve
à proximité du barrage réservoir de
champaubert est complètement inondé par
les eaux de la blaise fermes et maisons
d'habitation en subissent les méfaits et
les dégâts sont d'ores et déjà
importants citons construit sur un
plateau de la ceinture verte de
l'agglomération bordelaise inspire de
sérieuses inquiétudes à la suite d'un
affaissement de terrain
les habitants ont remarqué il ya
quelques jours la formation de fissures
dans le sol dû aux pluies de cet hiver
particulièrement humide
alertés les personnalités locales dont
monsieur madrelle députés et des experts
géologues se sont rendus sur les lieux
pour se rendre compte des dégâts et
prendre les mesures de protection
nécessaires mais monsieur ducos maire de
cénac puis madame deschamps une
habitante du hameau nous en disent
davantage 18 février les habitants nous
savons le jonc prévenu qu'il y avait une
lézarde apparent on tend vers de cette
voie immédiatement nous avons prévenu le
service des mines lesquels nous devons
rendre marche se sont rendus sur place
avec beaucoup de diligence de même qu'à
la protection civile
et après une étude approfondie dans le
sous sol ils ont donné l'ordre de faire
évacuer tout le hameau il faut vous dire
que en sous sol il y a des carriers
superposés qui date depuis fort
longtemps nous en extrayons la pierre
une pierre relativement l'a peut-être
pas très dur et par suite d'infiltration
des eaux les piliers se sont imprégnés à
tel point que quelques-uns ont cédé et
petit à petit il y aura tout de même pas
mal qui doivent s'aider dans l'avenir
comme la cause que l'on constaté le
service des mines et des médias pour
tout le monde nous sommes évidemment
chaviré nous avons passé deux jours en
pleurer puis il faudra maintenant faire
face et que c'est une perte matérielle
réparable rien tout est là c'est nous en
famille etc affectivement
malgré tout la volonté de la
municipalité ou la préfecture ça ne
pourra rien n'ont pas encore évolué
madame non nous partons jeudi puisqu'ils
n'ont pas de logement pour l'instant ils
sont réquisitionnés je le mets à fait ça
très vite est remarquablement comme il y
à t'il d'habitants dans le hameau de
sitôt eh bien il ya une dizaine de
familles qui habitent dont six à vis de
toute l'année c'est unique les
principales tout l'amour doit être
évacué tout le monde sait ça qu
ingénieur en chef des mines beaucoup
insister là dessus les catégories bien
souhaitons qu'une solution heureuse soit
trouvée dans les délais les plus rapides
en france les syndicats ne sont ne
semble pas très chaud pour reconstituer
un fonds commun avec la cgt il ya
quelques jours monsieur ces geeks et le
secrétaire général de la cgt a écrit à
toutes les centrales syndicales pour
leur proposer de se rencontrent afin de
mettre sur pied une plate forme
revendicative commune qui prévoirait
notamment en matière de salaire pas de
rémunération mensuelle inférieure à 1000
francs la réduction de la durée du
travail notamment l'abaissement de l'âge
de la retraite à 60 ans la réforme de la
civ fiscalité et la liberté syndicale et
politique des contrats la cfdt répond ce
matin
peu d'éléments nouveaux dans les
propositions de la cgt cependant nous
allons les étudier pendant deux jours
force ouvrière y répondre rien de changé
dans les rangs des syndicats communistes
et enfin il est probable que la fen la
fédération de l'éducation nationale ne
dépassera pas le stade des contacts avec
la cgt
vous savez que plusieurs manifestations
étaient prévues aujourd'hui l'une de
l'ordre nouveau qui est un mouvement
d'extrême droite devait se tenir à la
mutualité
l'autre était organisée par l'unef et
bien la préfecture de police a interdit
ces deux manifestations
l'unef à renoncer aux manifestations de
rue mais a décidé de tenir un meeting au
centre censier plus de peur que de mal
pour serge reggiani
je crois que nous attendions une faute
de serge à diane heavin ne vient pas ça
ne n'est pas bien grave serge reggiani a
fait trois tonneaux la nuit dernière du
côté de rennes il a dérapé sur une
plaque de verglas
le voici et avec son attachée de presse
il a eu quelques conclusions il a
regagné paris par le train il va subir
un examen médical mais il n'est pas
amants blessé il a quelques hématomes
patrick chapuis nous allons parler de
sport maintenant est d'abord de basket
ball oui j'ai commencé par le basket je
vous soumets cet incident qui avait
éclaté entre vichy et le mans le mans
avait emporté par 81 81 mais au bénéfice
d'un coup franc tiré dans des conditions
litigieuses en effet la faute avait été
sifflé semble-t-il après la fin du match
la commission des arbitres la cornue et
finalement le match nul a été rétablie
puisque le score est de 80 80 ce qui
fait bien là furent de vichy qui se
retrouve seul en tête avec 56 points de
vente un type 55 points et le mans 52
points en ski c'est aujourd'hui la
reprise du grand cirque blanc le grand
chapiteau est dressé à vancouver au
canada
les épreuves seront dominées par la
coupe du monde de ski alpin
car avant que le classement final soit
établie il reste encore trois épreuves à
courir
celle de vancouver celle de heaven les
vallées et ensuite une épreuve en
norvège
karl chance patrick russel et gustavo
tony ne sont toujours séparés que par 6
points
et pour avoir une chance de battre
chance bruxelles doit encore gagner deux
géants et tony de slalom
ce qui paraît assez difficile à tout
autre climat à nouméa un record de
france de natation vient d'être battu
il s'agit du 4 x 100 m féminin le
nouveau record et le 4 minutes 38
secondes et 87 centièmes il a été établi
par dolores hanevi ghislaine jo selon et
brigitte et nicole brulin nous allons
voir maintenant un aspect un peu
particulier de la boxe il s'agit de la
boxe française de la savatte les
championnats de france cette spécialité
avait lieu hier soir à la mutualité et
pierre fut là a passé une bonne partie
de la soirée avec ses spécialistes du
coup de pied figuré du coup de pied
chasse et oui la boxe française c'est
l'art de combattre avec ses poings et
ses pieds mais ce sport éducatif dans
les origines remontent à la savate a
beaucoup évolué et les assauts courtois
d'antan ou l'ardeur des adversaires
étaient freinés n'existe plus
aujourd'hui les combattants cherche à
conclure les coups de pied sous les
coups de poing deviennent meurtrier
lorsque les sens précis comme ce fut le
cas lors du combat qui opposera le
français guillaume à gauche en sombre
aux belges salvioli ici victime d'un
coup de pied figure vous allez le voir
le belge fut compté 8 ha sont très
appréciés par monsieur committee
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et aux
sports et georges carpentier salvioli
malmenés au cours des deux premières
reprises tenta bien de contrer christian
guillaume en boxant mais le français
devait conclure ce combat par un coup de
pied de pointe au foie qui fit plier le
belge christian guillaume sortait
vainqueur de cette rencontre par ko
technique
juste un petit mot pour dire que dans
huit villes de france commence ce soir
les championnats du monde de handball et
jacqueline alexandre nous avons
maintenant ouvrir notre page magazine et
vous allez nous parler de lui low-tech
car vous êtes la grande spécialiste ès
ludothèque
mais si je ne sais pas mais savez vous
d'abord tous ce qu'est une ludothèque
c'est exactement le même principe qu'une
bibliothèque
mais au lieu de prêter des livres elle
prête tout simplement déjoué
voici un reportage de france vérité avec
la participation d'une station de dix
jours à dijon l'association
bourguignonne culturelle connu surtout
pour ses spectacles ses voyages a créé
il y à un peu plus d'un an une lui de
secte il existait déjà des bibliothèques
des discothèques de près pourquoi ne pas
organiser en effet un prêt de jouer
quelques unes ont déjà été organisés au
canada en inde à new delhi dans les pays
nordiques
c'est la première de cette sorte en
france mais laissons la parole à madame
falls vice présidente de l'association
il ya certainement des jeux auxquels la
france attache qu'il faut qu'il garde en
toute propriété ce sont les jouets en
peluche ce sont les poupées tout à
caractère affectif et qui ne peuvent pas
évidemment être prêté mais la plupart
des jouets minguet tous doivent
développer chez l'enfant un certain
nombre de sens de connaissances et
également si vous voulez doivent se
développer chez lui des possibilités
manuelle ou intellectuelle
ou même artistique différente
donc il y as intérêt à multiplier les
jouets et l'oeuf ans se sépare du jouet
facilement l'enfant se sépare très
facilement de se jouer parce que le la
durée du prêt a été choisi en fonction
d'un certain de données psychologiques
qui ont été donnés par des psychologues
et au delà d'une semaine l'enfant
risquerait d'avoir un sens de propriété
sur le jouer et il lui serait difficile
de le rendre lors d'une semaine il a
largement le temps de de se servir du
jouet dans un musée et il est certain
que ils l'ont retrouve il le dépose mais
il le dépose dans un endroit qui connaît
une ludothèque qu'ils fréquentent chaque
semaine ou tous les quinze jours
il peut donc retrouver à n'importe quel
moment le jouet qui lui a plu alors
qu'est ce que tu as choisi la montagne
quand j'ai des questions ont posé six
ans tout en fermant les guit la wilaya
une petite carte ou alors où par exemple
l'aïe a marqué l insecte
en fait on est libye alors là certains
sur le sur le z
on doit donner vie tu es là
avec le nom la première lettre c'est un
jeu qui se joue à plusieurs
tu as plusieurs frères et soeurs ses
pages avec des petits camarades et gym
petits camarades chez toi tu es beaucoup
de joie wisches est-ce que tu prends
soin des jouets que tu prends ici niche
oui oui tu te sens une certaine
responsabilité
oui parce que c'est surtout parce que
c'est pas les miens et puis c'est
apprendre à bouger des pays sur lesquels
tu as vendu un jouet aujourd'hui quoi il
ya déjà plus s'il est déjà oubliée alors
tu l'a rendu très facilement ça t'as pas
fait mal au coeur de le rendre l'avenir
de la ludothèque est ce que vous avez
comme prochain lundi analyse au tec est
sans limite
parce que il faudrait déjà d'abord
pouvoir d'ouvrir un plus grand nombre
d'enfants
il faudrait disposer d'une place plus
importante il faudrait ouvrir tous les
jours
il faudrait trouver des jouets neufs et
jouez pas neuf déjouer nouveau saisir
qui correspondent à une optique tout à
fait différent il faudrait d'autre part
apporter ses jouets à des enfants à la
campagne pouvoir multiplier les prêts et
les diffusions
il faudrait que nous ayons près de nous
une équipe de gens qui apprennent aux
enfants à jouer qui recueille leurs
impressions et qui sait pourquoi pas que
nous demandions aux enfants une
collaboration dans la création de jouets
bien nous allons suivre maintenant le
flash philatélique de jacqueline corps
en cette fin de semaine verra la mise en
vente anticipée les 28 février et 1er
mars en la salle des fêtes de l'institut
national des invalides 6 boulevard des
invalides d'un nouveau timbre français
honorons le maréchal juin
souvenirs philatéliques signé de la
maréchal juin et du graveur pierre
gandon vendu exclusivement au profit des
oeuvres sociales du corps
expéditionnaire français en italie voici
brièvement retracé à travers les timbres
poste là
la carrière de ce grand militaire
français né à beaune
il était le fils d'un gendarme c'est à
constantine où son père venait garnison
qui grandit boursiers il se distingue à
l'école militaire de saint-cyr d'où il
sort premiers d'une promotion de 200
joules lieutenant dès 1913 alphonse juin
reçoit le baptême du feu au maroc en
france il sera blessé à deux reprises au
cours des batailles de la marne et de
soissons il est fait chevalier dans
l'ordre de la légion d'honneur en
décembre 1914 après la guerre le
maréchal lyautey l'appel à son
état-major à rabat puis à paris il
participe ensuite à la bataille du rif
plus tard on le retrouve colonel du 3e
régiment de zouaves de constantine puis
général de brigade alger rappelé en
métropole il commande la 15e division
d'infanterie motorisée qu'il conduit en
mai 1940 sur le fond de namur
il défend valenciennes les faubourgs de
lille mais est fait prisonnier avec les
débris de sa division interne et que
nick stagne près de dresde
il est libéré en juillet 1941 sur la
demande du général weygand qui vie
confie la remise en condition de l'armée
d'afrique
cette dernière protégera le débarquement
allié face aux unités allemandes qui
arrive à bizerte et participera à la
campagne de tunisie qui sent le général
juin aurait peut-être été perdu en tout
cas gagné beaucoup plus tard c'est à la
tête du corps expéditionnaire français
qu'il débarque à naples en novembre 43 6
mois plus tard ce sera la bataille du
garigliano qui ouvrit la route de rome
puis sienne
florence et la libération du territoire
national en avril 1945 le général juin
se rend à san francisco où l'on élabore
la charte des nations unies
il accompagne ensuite au général de
gaulle à moscou puis il est chargé de
mission exceptionnelle en chine et en
indochine élevé à la dignité de maréchal
de france en 1952 il sera d'autre part
l'année suivante
élu membre de l'académie française après
59 ans passés au service de la patrie
il s'éteint le 27 janvier 1967 et depuis
repose sous le dôme des invalides où
près de ses illustres devanciers grandes
figures comme lui de l'armée française
notre administration postale nous
annonce d'autre part à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale de la lutte contre le
cancer
l'émission hors programme d'un timbre
dont le premier jour aura lieu les 4 et
5 avril à la faculté de médecine de
paris
la prochaine exposition philatélique
interpète ce qui aura lieu à new york
les 13 et 14 mars prochains
nouveau cette année une innovation une
liaison postale par hovercraft en effet
pour la première fois un transport de
courrier aura lieu entre ottawa et new
york par hydroglisseur seul moyen de
transport qui puisse durant les hivers
canadiens circuler aussi bien sur loup
que sur les classes les souvenirs
philatéliques du port seront revêtus
d'un affranchissement mixte canada etats
unis
mais revenons si vous le voulez bien à
paris pour regarder les images de
l'exposition qui s'y est déroulé samedi
et dimanche dernier en la salle du
gymnase de la porte d'ivry exposition à
l'occasion de la mise en vente anticipée
du timbre consacré au cinquième
championnat du monde de handball qui se
déroule cette année en france le
président de la fédération nationale de
handball accueillait monsieur maire
représentant le ministre des ptt et
monsieur van est représentant la
direction générale des postes
l'exposition ne comprenait que des
participations thématiques ayant pour
sujet les sports et plus
particulièrement les jeux olympiques
présentations diverses avec bloc de
quatre cartes maximum et que chez
premier jour pour nous c'est un bref
historique du handball que nous vous
proposons si vous ne les possédez pas
encore procuré les vous vite demain soir
seront retirés de la vente les timbres
organisation internationale du travail
et châlons sur marne
nous nous retrouverons si vous le voulez
bien lundi 2 mars à 22h50 pour notre
magazine mensuel télé philatélie au
revoir nous allons maintenant
directement à la bourse de paris où nous
achetons gérard vidal hanche
voyez des visages jeunes il en a
effectivement la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui le marché est très nerveux
il ya des valeurs en majorité en baisse
bien sûr comme toujours des titres se
distinguent et monte mais dans
l'ensemble le marché est plutôt décousu
et les baisses l'emportent
pourquoi et bien il ya un certain nombre
de facteurs très rapidement je vous les
énumère d'une part on constate une
certaine diminution des rentrées de
devises
d'autre part nos exportateurs épreuve
éprouvent des difficultés à
l'exportation parce qu'il ya un
ralentissement des échanges sur le plan
mondial
puis troisièmement il ya des
restrictions de crédit et les
industriels en souffre beaucoup
il y a tout de même des éléments
favorables le plan de redressement est
en bonne voie et surtout les résultats
financiers des sociétés qui sont
déclarés actuellement son fort rebond
l'année le millésime 69 sera une
excellente année
quoi qu'il en soit comme vous allez le
voir tout de suite en tard par exemple
abaissé à l'ouverture
toutes les valeurs françaises de ce
secteur du reste sont en baisse qu'il
s'agit des pétroles d'aquitaine la
française des pétroles ou de la
française des pétroles bp il ya là un
contraste entre la baisse des valeurs
françaises et la baisse des valeurs
pétrolières étrangères qui sont en
hausse
en effet la standard oil lui jersey et
la royal dutch sont très recherchés sur
les bourses étrangères
pourquoi vous savez que c'est ce sont
les séquelles de la sphère antar à tort
ou à raison les financiers estime que
l'industrie pétrolière a été en quelque
sorte en partie nationalisée par
l'histoire en tard c'est à dire la prise
de contrôle de dents tard par le groupe
pétrolier elf air au magasin des
galeries lafayette aujourd'hui se
ressaisissent les magasins paris france
vont probablement annoncer une
répartition d'actions gratuits une pour
10 la société très coutumière de sept de
ses distributions favorable aux
actionnaires
elle les pratiques tous les voiliers que
les pétroles d'aquitaine sont à leur
plus bas niveau de l'année 486 plus bas
de l'année en fait c'est depuis 69
janvier 69 486 aujourd'hui la sienne des
mines en revanche et en os je vous
l'avais signalé hier voyez que le
mouvement se poursuit 254
aujourd'hui il y a également du côté des
valeurs american des hausses mais ceci
en raison de du redressement de wall
street hier à la métallurgie à la
construction mécanique très bonne tenue
en revanche dans ce secteur usineurs il
y a deux jours avait atteint son niveau
record
laissez la conjoncture très favorable
dans la sidérurgie française qui
favorise la bonne tenue de ses titres de
denain à la chaire ces aigris également
y compris vallourec vous voyez pas ce
tableau mais qui est très recherchée
dans le secteur de la transformation des
métaux aux banques
la financière de paris qui va annoncer
dans quelques heures les convictions son
émission d'actions se tient bien
michelin en revanche a glissé en dessous
de 17 cents à 799 on annonce du côté des
chimiques
vous allez voir les cours qui sont en
baisse de bons résultats en ce qui
concerne jean kullmann les dirigeants
honteux déclaré devant des journalistes
hier est d'abord que la société
n'entendait pas modifier sa stratégie il
n'y aura pas d'éclatement des actes des
actifs du gym kullmann
qui a une double vocation à la fois de
producteur chimique est également de
producteurs de d'alliages spéciaux et de
métaux ugine kuhlmann va entreprendre un
très gros programme de développement
notamment pour les aciers spéciaux grâce
à des installations nouvelles à fos et
enfin le président a annoncé que les
perspectives restent très favorable pour
70 pechiney où vous l'avez vu était en
baisse aujourd'hui bien que l'on
s'attende également à de bons résultats
pour 69 et à une majoration du dividende
hausse des américaines en effet il a
fallu simplement qu'une petite banque de
philadelphie annonce hier légère détente
des taux d'intérêt pour que wall street
la bourse de new york la grande bourse
américaine s'enflamme et il ya eu de
très forte hausse
en voici les tracés la bourse paris
general motors et it était marché de
leur très calme c'est le calme plat
toujours sur le métal jaune le lingot
vos 6370 moins différent aujourd'hui
tandis que le napoléon et à son même
cours d'hier 58 francs 10 c'était la
bourse de paris
à vous les studios mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs merci de votre
attention au revoir à demain